aber herzlich willkommen meine trocken
hält heute gibt es von mir ein ganz
schnell das rezept ich werde heute
nutella brötchen herstellen
das gibt's bei uns jetzt gleich zum
frühstück und was ihre zutaten benötigt
zeige ich euch jetzt
dafür braucht ihr nur vier zutaten und
zwar ist es ein etwas hotel oder eine
andere füllung etwas milch und
blätterteig normalerweise nehme ich
immer rechteckigen blätterteig diesmal
habe ich aus was den runden genommen
aber das macht auch nichts ich zeige
euch jetzt einfach wie das mit dem
runden blätterteig geht
ich verwende ganz gerne fertigen
blätterteig denn es lohnt sich einfach
nicht bereit selbst zu stellen
ich hab das schon ein paar mal gemacht
aber ich finde da ist die arbeit einfach
viel zu groß mit diesen touren und
wieder einschlagen wieder kühl stellen
aus sieht man dann auch wie viel butter
in seinem stück blätterteig drin ist das
muss man nicht unbedingt und deswegen
empfehle ich euch auch als ihr könnt es
mal probiert selber zu machen
ich kann mich auch gern mal ein rezept
dazu oder ein video dazu veröffentlichen
wenn ihr interesse habt aber ich finde
es lohnt sich einfach fast gar nicht und
wenn ihr den fertigen blätterteig immer
da habt dann könnte auch die
tiefkühltruhe stecken könnt ihr dann
rausholen und etwas antauen lassen kann
man hier schon weiter verwenden und so
geht es einfach viel schneller
ihr habt ihn nicht mal zehn minuten die
heimlichen fertig gestellt und können
sie dann auch schon warten
jetzt möchte ich euch nicht länger auf
die folter spannen und seid euch jetzt
wie das geht
hier kommt jetzt einfach etwas milch und
das allein
ich habe das miteinander erklärt dass
ständig kurz zur seite
hier habe ich mir schon mein backpapier
vorbereitet auf mainburg
dann nehme ich mir hier in blätterteig
der ist mir jetzt noch etwas zu dick
deswegen war ich dennoch mit etwas mehl
aus
zum vergleich so groß war vorher und so
groß ist er jetzt
dann schneidet mir den ich gleich große
dreiecke erst dran ihren vierteln und
jetzt mache ich noch die hierdurch 3 und
rändern mit der eigelb masse bestreichen
dann nehme ich mir meinen teller und
geht sich in jede ecke in kleinen
teelöffel und dann werden die jetzt
aufgerollt ich war jetzt mal hier an
ich wollte es zur mitte hin auf und
drückt hier die ränder fest damit
einfach zum hotel später eine packung
nicht ausläuft und dann das mache ich
zwei mal um sicher zu gehen und dann
hole ich es einfach locker auf und legt
es hier auch mein backblech beim
auflegen passe ich auf dass die spitze
unten bleibt
der markt kann die heimlichen auch mit
anderen leckeren sachen fühlen
ich werde zeit zum beispiel noch 08 als
füllung benutzen oder einfach ein paar
schokoladenmädchen ihr könnt aber zum
beispiel auch madsen wahrnehmen oder
geräte netze die mit etwas fossilen oder
zimt verrühren
also da könnt ihr echt machen wir jetzt
möchtet ihr könnt natürlich auch
bekannte füllungen nehmen mit kartoffeln
füllung oder etwas käse etwas sinken
also da könnt ihr einfach das benutzen
was euch schmeckt ich mache einfach ganz
gerne diese note erhalten weil sie
schnell gehen und man eigentlich jeder
bei uns nutella ziemlich gerne mag
bei der nugg.ad variante schneidet ihr
einfach etwas nur den würfel und leg
dich so traub und dann wird einfach
genauso aufgerollt wie bei den nutella
hörnchen
so sehen die herren von dem aus ihr
könnt sie jetzt noch wenn ihr wollt mit
etwas gelb milch mischung bestreichen
ihr könnt aber auch so lassen ich
bestreite mal die hälfte damit damit ihr
später nach dem backen den unterschied
sehen könnt
sie jetzt bei 200 grad backen
ich glaube wir brauchen so etwas 15
minuten nach dem jahrzehnt so aus ihr
könnt deutlich sehen dass hier die den
verstrichen sind schön glänzen
und die die nicht gestrichen sie neben
markt sind ich habs jetzt 17 minuten im
ofen gebacken
es waren zwei minuten so viel man sieht
auch hier dass die ränder etwas zu
dunkel geworden sind aber so sind sie
eigentlich auch ganz schön
ihr könnt jetzt zu lassen oder sie mit
etwas puderzucker bestäuben und dann
könnte sie kalt oder warm essen
die schmecken auch super zum mittags
kaffee oder tee aber wir essen die jetzt
zum frühstück die hölzl natürlich nicht
nur ganz lecker zum frühstück ihr könnt
ihr natürlich auch mittags zum kaffee
oder tee servieren soll ich das ganz
gerne auch mal will unangekündigter
besuch vor der tür stehen diesen so
schnell gemacht und so schnell fertig
und schmecken auch unheimlich lecker
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen wird euch eine schöne zeit
und bis zum nächsten mal tschüss